[Music]
neural networks in 10 seconds oh
um
let me think about this one so i think
uh neural networks i would
what comes to mind when i hear that is
this idea of trying to
teach a computer to learn something from
data rather than being directly
instructed by a human talking to another
person it's a lot easier to teach a
person how to identify a dog by showing
them different dogs and they can sort of
get the gist of it and figure it out
then by giving them a set of rules and
things to look for like it has ears and
has this and that um because so many
other things have that as well that's
way longer than 10 seconds but it's
short think about pattern recognition
like building algorithms that can do
efficient pattern recognition but
you're actually trying to get these
pattern recognition algorithms to do
automated tasks
layers of like statistic statistical
processes where you have an input and
based off of these um
things that you have in the middle some
outcomes
i feel like that was really bad
um
i can read that one later maybe
how hard it is to separate pluses from
minus in a graph
all depends on kind of how they're
distributed in that picture when your
network's all about is how do you
reshape the picture so that drawing a oh
that's a terrible explanation that's so
hard okay learning to compose
uh simple functions
over and over again to solve really hard
problems
artificial neural networks are
digital structures that mimic the human
neural networks
to compute tasks
neural nets are basically function
approximators that are built on
sort of intuition that we have about how
the brain works
[Music]
neural networks is basically a
matrix multiplication and a
non-linearity plus
auto
grad also differentiation
and allows you to approximate any
functions you want theoretically but
that doesn't happen because they have
intrinsic biases
big big big matrices
lots of matrix multiplication
nonlinear functions make everything work
neural networks are really big
complicated machines
with lots and lots of knobs and dials
and
learning a neural network is just tuning
these knobs and dials correctly and how
do you tune these knobs and dials
with the derivative with gradient
descent in order to minimize some loss
you need to figure out the way to tune
these knobs and
one just dials someone else's answer
[Music]